[Applause]
i love to say i told you
that's one of my favorite things that's
true i told you so that's true
it's literally one of my favorite things
to say to people
i think on this very podcast one week
ago yep to this day
i believe it was one week ago to this
day i said
exactly how style bender was gonna whoop
this [ __ ] juiced up [ __ ]
paulo costa's ass okay who's talking
crazy [ __ ]
yo talking crazy [ __ ] and then got
humbled and i said exactly how i was
gonna break it down i thought it was
gonna take a little bit longer i did say
that i thought it was gonna be maybe
third or fourth round
i didn't realize that izzy was gonna get
him out of there in a second embarrassed
him
embarrassing surgical god surgical so if
you all know what you're talking about
you missed one of the most exciting
fights we've seen in recent history
uh israel had sonia uh friend of the
show
um amazing mma fighter ufc middleweight
champion
destroyed demolished paulo costa ah just
dismantled
dismantled surgical i mean unbelievable
like if you're like a nerd about fights
and again i don't know that much about
mma i'm a huge boxing fan
so i understand the striking side of mma
way better than i understand like the
grappling and the wrestling like i just
don't
i just don't know about it right i don't
know the strategy i don't know what
they're trying to do and
it looks cool when they're down there
with the jiu jitsu it can be like boring
at times but
i just don't understand it but striking
i understand
and seeing his approach seeing izzy's
approach
to taking out costa was unbelievable
incredible like first of all it was so
brilliant that he attacks the leg
right it was actually the same strategy
did yep
go who do you think same strategy he
used against romero so a little
yes but like a little bit different
because uh romero wouldn't
engage with him but the idea but the
idea was going after leg but
what i would say is it was the same
strategy as his teammate
used against max holloway by izzy's
teammate
right max holloway has this amazing jab
he's an amazing striker
and what izzy's teammate did is he
attacked that
opening leg in their first fight okay
and that limited max's ability to jab a
limited max ability to strike and that's
what izzy did right here
paul acosta comes straight forward he's
a bruiser right
so what izzy did he starts attacking
that [ __ ] leg and now
paula casa is one afraid to come forward
too afraid to put any weight on it if
you're not putting any weight on your
front leg
how are you supposed to throw punches
with power yeah and he was setting him
up for these strikes i mean it was
amazing like
he would pump fake a leg kick polycaster
would bring his leg up to block it
and the second he brought it back down
then he fires the real leg kick
i mean just destroyed it and the guy was
just broken you saw him out there just
[ __ ] broke him
pieced him up took him out there it was
just beautiful it was absolutely
you know what was cool is he been on
this podcast a couple times for those of
you who don't know
and the first time he came on he hadn't
won any belts but he talked about how
power doesn't mean what people think it
means he's like i don't need power i got
precision he said that exact thing
he was like i will hit you exactly where
i want to hit you over and over again
and you will fall it might have the same
power behind it as these meat heads
but you will fall and to watch a guy
manifest everything he said to this
point of super stardom
and dismantling this monster if you look
at them on the screen you're scared for
izzy
and i don't know [ __ ] about mma or
fighting in general yeah i was a little
scared for izzy but he did exactly what
he said he was gonna do three years ago
and it got him exactly where he said he
was gonna go so [ __ ] cool
yeah to see that happen yeah man it's i
think and again i said it last week
uh so i don't wanna repeat too much of
it but i i wasn't nervous for izzy just
because i know how big he is i think a
lot of people don't realize how big he
is and i swear when he does like the
weigh-ins
he slouches or like spreads his legs
wide so it look he looks smaller but
when he goes face to face with the guys
he kind of looks almost their height
and then on fight day he's like a whole
head taller than him somehow i don't
know how the [ __ ] he manages to do that
but
that's kind of [ __ ] with you a little
bit [ __ ] with your confidence you think
you're as tall as a dude you're about to
fight and then the next day he's a whole
head taller than you
yeah i mean i just thought looking at
just the size of the
whatever the mask i was like oh this
guy's huge is [ __ ] costa
and he's on juice is he said that the
first time he came here he also said
three years ago i want to take costa
cause
before the usda or whatever yeah usada
gets him i want to get him because i
know he's on steroids
yeah so he called costa three years ago
yeah i want to get him and
you see this guy looks like a [ __ ]
juice head and you're like yo i'm a
little scared i again not knowing
anything's like yo i'm scared for izzy
and just embarrassed him like you said
you watch casa try to like
be a showman the first round second
round that's all gone yeah
two minutes into the second round he's
knocked out submitted and then izzy
[ __ ]
ass [ __ ] him twice literally panama's
ass [ __ ] him
twice and then gets off it was just
incredible to watch
yeah it's just amazing man i think that
was the first time i seen somebody go
down with a temple shot that didn't hit
like flush yeah like it like grazed
them and his legs were gone yeah and
it's really interesting because
paulo costa was known for having a
really good chin like he's been in
brawls with people
like he was in a brawl with joel romero
yeah not
a fight where it's a jab fest
that you're being super strategic and
like maybe you're touching people but
not full power
we're talking about all out brawl and
izzy
dropped this guy like it was nothing it
was on a graze
it was almost like he was ready to go
down i think izzy caught him with a leg
kick before
yeah and that's followed up with that
yeah but man it was just [ __ ] amazing
to see
and everybody is real quiet right now
all the people out there that was like
they were criticizing izzy for the
romero fight remember like oh it's a
boring fight he's like yeah because
romero was terrified
yeah romero knows and listen i don't
want to say another man is terrified of
fighting you know they would do
something i'm not [ __ ] doing it all
but
romero knows that that was his fate if
he tried to engage right i actually
credit paulo costa
i credit him for like trying to do what
he thought he was going to do against
izzy
nobody's going to do that against izzy i
don't care who you are nobody's doing
that against is he not in the
middleweight division
and honestly maybe not in the light
heavyweight division
like it changes because there's a
different he doesn't have the same like
length and size advantage but the speed
advantage he'd have over those light
heavyweights
and his just his striking ability i
don't know any light heavyweight that
can strike with him
and he's not going to bang with you he's
going to be in and out pick you apart
strategically break you down make you
move into certain positions and then
capitalize on those positions like
it's a wrap bro so impressive this is
what i'm worried about who's he going to
fight next
like it was so dominant right it was i
know everybody's
saying right now because there's this
new guy in the ufc that fought three
times in a couple months his name is
hamzat
something like that he is like a cleft
palate right and uh
i think is he called him rat lip which
is really fun and uh
and he's very impressive he had like a
big knockout against his journeyman
fighter but
it's a very different game when you're
knocking out journeyman fighters and
you're going up against
the best in the world and could who
could be the greatest to ever do it when
he retires
like this is his hundredth combat sport
victory
you know what i mean he's 20-0 in the
mma
75 and like four or something like that
in kickboxing
like five in one in boxing like this guy
could go down is the best
he really could yeah i think uh some
people were predicting that this guy
jared cannon here yeah he's so what
izzy's at the point right now and a lot
of like fighters get to this point where
like you actually have to promote
your opponents right because like the
reason this fight was exciting is
because we all thought
casa had a chance yeah and what i'm
concerned about is he was so dominant
over casa is that we start going well
who the [ __ ] going to be able to fight
him
right because then you lose an opponent
there's one fight left
who john bones jones well john bones
left light heavyweight so he's
middleweight right yeah light
heavyweight is one above that
and he left that to go to heavyweight
right could he drop down a light
heavyweight does he go up to light
heavyweight
potentially but he just left his belt he
relinquished the belt
right so like you leave the belt
to fight for
the same weight without the belt it
doesn't make sense to me i think what
john bones is doing is okay let me go
see if i can do some heavyweight fights
and see if i can get another belt up
there
right which i think makes sense and now
they're talking back and forth on
instagram or like twitter or whatever it
is and we'll see what happens
but and it would be a cool fight we'll
see what happens but
um but yeah i mean like i just don't
know who he ends up fighting cannoneer's
got to fight the guy that izzy just
beat yeah right robert whitaker yeah
robert whitaker so
that's what as he said after his fight
right that's why he's talking about yeah
he said if you win this you're next
yeah you get it next but it's like like
he has to build up cannoneer yeah
so candy near has to have this super
dominant win and then we're excited
about the izzy fight
but he's been so dominant that i can't
even name another person can you guys
name another person
no the closest fight he had was gaston
gasoline was the close fight he had and
that's another thing that i'm starting
to realize and i gotta
i gotta talk to izzy i've been messaging
him a little bit afterwards but i gotta
break him down
like just break down his thinking about
this
i don't know if izzy is getting
better like i think he's been this elite
a striker
as long as he's been maybe in kickboxing
and he's i don't think he's learning
more
kickboxing per se by being in mma i
think what it is is
in his earlier fights and i gotta ask
him about this but he's
he was less confident of his ability in
mma
he knew he was a beast with kickboxing
but now he's entering this field where
he's like
well i'm not an elite grappler and i'm
not an elite wrestler
and i might have to do those things in
this fight so i got to be i oh i got to
be on my p's and q's
right and i think what's starting to
happen is especially with gaston gaslin
was a wrestling background guy
you know and i think what happened is as
he's
just destroyed the elite fighters
in the division i think his confidence
has built up in terms of what he can't
handle
and i think this last performance was
like oh
it don't matter if you're a professional
wrestler it'll matter if you're an ncaa
wrestler it don't matter if you're a
gold medalist he did say i will destroy
you he just after the gasoline fight
when he went the distance he's like
there's a level of confidence i have now
that's even
higher like i feel different yeah so i
wonder if that's what it is it's not
necessarily skill per se that's
improving but it's just confidence in
his skills
that's improvement but yeah man i'm
excited i'm excited for what's happened
you know next with him and who knows i
really hope that this guy jared cannon
or whatever
has an amazing fight against whitaker
and then destroys them so it can be
built up but if like
if whitaker beats cannoneer i don't need
to see izzy fight whitaker again no
yeah you literally knocked whitaker out
twice
cold in the same fight he gets saved by
the bell
i think in the first round or the second
round and then in the third round
you knock them out completely do we need
to see that fight again no no
nobody's excited about that 100 but yo
shouts to izzy man
we got to get izzy on the show you know
when all this i'm sure he's you know in
mid celebration but all this is done man
you got to come back on here when you're
in new york you got to come back on
flavor man
we love you brother we're proud of you
man and keep up the great work keep
knocking these [ __ ] out
don't ever let them don't ever let them
try to disrespect
without paying a price there's a price
for disrespect watching hizzy rub
it in too man i missed most of the
pre-fight trash talking i loved it
just the little bits i saw with the
white belt that costa brought and all
that [ __ ]
so corny yeah and then izzy just man
just owned it
yeah and how funny was it that like he
ends up mounting him at the end yeah
and then the [ __ ] thing was
absolutely hilarious absolutely
hilarious anyway
congratulations kiddo man we're proud of
you over here you keep it up all right
you